my name is constantine buehler and i'm a
partner at sequoia capital
i formerly was at meretech where i
co-founded the ai 50 list with forbes in
2019. when i went into venture capital
i was focused on artificial intelligence
companies and
i got to look at a lot of really
interesting companies
but what i realized very quickly is that
not every company that said that they
were ai
really had a lot of ai to it in fact
there was a lot of snake oil in the
industry
many of the ai companies that i was
reviewing
had very little ai or very little
company i realized wow
there is a lot of confusion for people
who are interested in artificial
intelligence but don't know
exactly where to start and that's when i
approached forbes to
consider the ai50 idea what are the
young people
excited about they're excited about
quite frankly
leveraging their domain knowledge on top
of the technology space right so
they're interested in designing the
algorithms
um doing machine learning i am really
seeing
uh that the young people that i work
with the students
become more engaged in that space and i
can tell you it's irrespective
of what what they're studying this seems
to have no boundaries
all 50 companies on this list have been
rigorously reviewed
for self-reported financial personnel
diversity culture growth
metrics both the companies that are
nominated and the companies that are in
the
open application receive the same
application
at that point we take those 100
applicants
and we give it to our world-class judges
these are
top artificial intelligence experts in
industry and in academia much like
earlier
disruptive ways of technology uh from
the
personal computer to the internet to
mobile
i think ai maybe even more than the
previous waves of disruption
is transforming every industry so i
speak of ceos
in everything from manufacturing to
retail to agriculture
to healthcare that are always trying to
figure out ai
i think with transform our community
collectively has transformed consumers
off the internet so large consumer
software internet companies use ai
really well
historically artificial intelligence has
not been
the most diverse field and this is an
area for
improvement throughout the industry in
this year's list
diversity and inclusion was a
significant part
of the rankings we're very happy to have
seen that
a lot of diverse founders co-founders
and companies
uh applied for the list and are being
included in the list this year
i think there are a number of factors
that go into that
investor bias when i took a look at data
that talks about what do the investors
actually
look like what is very very very
striking
and is that when you're talking about
venture backed
founders by race and ethnicity
i mean i think it's like i don't i think
it's like point
zero five percent that are black and
brown
and which which makes for a very small
sort of culturally competent and
awareness
of what happens in community i think the
lack of social capital
is a part of it and you tend to get
sameness
in smaller networks and i think a large
part of that
um happens when it comes to
women and black and brown technologists
as they're trying to
garner uh vc funding and the diversity
matters when it comes to
vc investors artificial intelligence
will be a part of
every company in 10 years and the
business leaders that
see that is the reality and adopt it
earlier
will have a strategic advantage will get
ahead
and will propel their businesses forward
because of it
the way for the u.s to retake a
greater leadership role in manufacturing
built for the next generation
not to try to rebuild the previous
generation
the faction is becoming digital this is
a process it's not a
where we're still on our way um and i
that's
uh the way to create more american jobs
in manufacturing
is to embrace digitization and ai
so that american workers can gain the
skills needed to build and deploy the
next generation of technologies in the
fight in the u.s
and around the world artificial
intelligence revolution has potential to
be
as big if not bigger than the internet
revolution
early innings as we're seeing now a lot
of the value in artificial intelligence
is going to that horizontal ai those
picks and shovels that will be
fueling the artificial intelligence
revolution
as the innings continue in this
incredible revolution
we're going to see more and more
companies that are actually
serving the customer on the application
layer helping
enterprises and individuals make better
decisions
faster each and every day